[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
it's
hump day
happy happy happy hump day
somebody's under investigation
oh i've been saying it for months and
months and months
and ever since we heard that john
eastman and jeffrey clark had their
electronic devices taken from them weeks
ago it was clear
it was clear that donald trump is under
investigation by the doj there was no
doubt in my mind
doubt me
doubt me i'm telling you if you are
still listening to people out there
clamoring on about how merrick garland
isn't gonna prosecute trump
you have your [ __ ] head up your ass
you are you're not paying attention
you're only paying attention to the lies
that the few are telling you
besides merrick garland isn't the one
who prosecutes here the department of
justice is
the entity that prosecutes
and the united states attorney graves in
dc
has a grand jury and is moving closer
and closer and closer to their target
our targets
as it were
and it's very clear it's becoming more
and more obvious as we watch
who is being at target in other words
who's taking what devices
jeffrey clark and john eastman having
their devices taken is very significant
that was significant news
that that ties trump directly directly
to a doj investigation folks not not
third or fourth in line directly he was
in direct communication with clark and
eastman we see the evidence in public at
the january 6 hearings stop
listening to don winslow on this subject
stop
tell him tweet at him stop talking about
this talk about something different
the number one personality trait that
you have left don is that merrick
garland isn't gonna prosecute trump this
is really [ __ ] dumb
really [ __ ] stupid and merrick
garland has said over and over and over
again it doesn't matter who it is
they do not give a [ __ ] who it is if
they committed crimes to try to stop the
certification of the vote and overthrow
our election in 2020
they will prosecute them
we are going to see state legislators
all these fake electors it is becoming
more clear that that looks like the
thrust of this
is the fake elector scheme
that john eastman jeffrey clark and
donald trump were trying to use and
trying to pressure state officials like
rusty bowers
we get news that mark short the chief of
staff of the vice president of the
united states who was the pivotal point
of the fake elector scheme
to get mike pence to certify the fake
electors not the real ones the actual
certified legal electors
so if you're still listening to the
[ __ ] puke artist on twitter about how
oh
hysteria trump will never go to jail
trump will never get charged
there'll never be accountability
you have your head up your ass
so stop it's enough stop stop the
nonsense
let's move forward let's all work
together to make sure these fascists
these goddamn white christian
nationalists do not take over our
government that is what we should be
doing not fighting whether the doj is
going to prosecute people it is clear
that they are going to prosecute people
there is no doubt in my mind that they
are going to prosecute people for the
january 6 not just the insurrection but
them trying to overthrow our vote in
2020.
they're going to prosecute
now who where what charges they give
that's the question of course that's the
question but that's the question left up
to the prosecutors because when they
swing
when they swing to hit trump and his
allies they have to connect
they have to connect they cannot whiff
on this one
we want them to do their due diligence
we want them to take time we know the
crimes that are committed we see them
with the select evidence the court of
public opinion can indict trump now
they can indict trump now
in 2022
and serve him his sentence and the rest
of his allies their sentence
in the midterm you can do that you have
the right you can still vote as of now
you let these white christian
nationalists take over our government
they may take that away from you just
like they're taking rights every day and
they want to take more and more and more
away from you
so stop complaining about the department
of justice doing their [ __ ] job
stop start getting activated start
getting engaged in your democracy do the
thing that we can do best
we the people which is democracy and
[ __ ]
they're terrified of it they're [ __ ]
terrified of it
absolutely terrified scared running
scared of democracy
so much so that they are referring to
themselves as white christian
nationalist
marjorie taylor green even embracing the
words
toxic masculinity saying yeah you
goddamn right we need toxic masculinity
we need toxic males all over the place
we need nazis is what she's saying we
need nazis is what she's saying
i want more white nazis
white christian nationalist is what
marjorie taylor green is saying
so stop with the [ __ ] the nonsense
and trying to [ __ ] gaslight people
that the doj isn't doing their job
enough of that [ __ ] we don't need to
listen to that [ __ ] from our side we
can we can put that aside tell them to
[ __ ] off and we can move on and save our
democracy here
it can happen we can do it
we can indict trump in public court
in the court of public opinion and we
can convict him in 2022.
it looks like
warnock
won't be debated by herschel walker
herschel walker's terrified of him john
fetterman is absolutely trouncing dr oz
that the new jersey resident running in
senate in pennsylvania
jd vance can't get a word in edgewise
with tim ryan because he's too busy
talking about how women who are in
violent relationships should have to
force to be stay to stay in those
marriages
we are on the verge of winning
we could do it we just have to band
together we just have to engage in the
ballot we have to have strategic outrage
you gotta stay pissed about the stuff
that matters not the stuff that doesn't
matter stop being pissed about whether
the department of justice is gonna do
something
go talk to your family and your friends
about the court of public opinion
go tell them the evidence that you saw
in the january 6 select hearings and the
more and more evidence that will pour
out
let the doj to their work
it's now time for you to be the
prosecutor
for you to sell the case against donald
trump and his allies now right now not
yesterday not last week right now to
sell that case to the american people
your friends your family your colleagues
your fellow parishioners parishioners
the people at the [ __ ] grocery store
it's time for you to convict donald
trump in the court of public opinion and
you are the prosecutor and you are
making the case
everywhere you go anyone you talk to
now's the time to engage in our
democracy
we can do this i'm very confident
and yesterday with the news
that donald trump is under investing
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock that was my
response yeah no [ __ ] he's under
investigation no [ __ ]
as if we haven't known this for months
the doj does not announce this [ __ ]
merrick garland merrick garland
convicted
he was the prosecutor on oklahoma city
the bombing in atlanta the olympics
and he never
said one public word about those
investigations not one
and got convictions in those cases
so be confident that merrick garden as
the head of the department of justice
will make sure the department of justice
itself does its job and graves the
united states attorney in washington dc
has a grand jury they're investigating
every single facet of january 6 which is
a lot of work and it's going to take a
lot of time but they're they're already
right there next to the trump the trumps
and his allies very close
when they're seizing jeffrey clark and
john eastman cell phones
that's damn close that's in the same god
damn room that trump was in that's where
the investigation is at folks
be confident in your institutions be
confident in your democracy stop
spreading anti-democracy messages around
if you're pro-democracy stop
to doubt our institutions and our
government only gives the fascist fodder
only gives them fodder
yes is it perfect no is justice always
served no
is our system broken in some places
absolutely
but if you allow them
the fascist
to spread doubt and to see this country
with the fascism that they want to
you may lose your democracy
so it's up to you
it's up to you to either believe this
this [ __ ] stupid nonsense about
merrick garland and and absolute
[ __ ] lies about how he's not or if
he is and all this nonsense if you just
go and look at his record and you look
at what he said on record since then
and you and you just look at the
investigation that we know publicly the
parts that we know publicly of course
they're investigating donald trump and
his allies of course they are
why do you think he grandpa poopypants
is freaking the [ __ ]
out freaking out about the [ __ ]
georgia phone call absolutely freaking
out
because i believe that that federal that
the georgia investigation into the phone
call and pressuring a brad rathberger
and the election officials in the state
of georgia
is a state case but it's a fed case too
it's a fed case with the state electors
it's a fed case with rusty bowers in
arizona the house speaker who has been
now ostracized because he told the
[ __ ] truth under oath
it's a fed case
and they're going to every single uh
every single rock that they can
turn over and see underneath i believe
the feds will find every single bit of
this evidence that they need to have and
the re one reason why folks is because
these idiots are buffoons
they're absolute buffoons
you just look at the case of john
eastman and donald trump alone trying to
convince mike pence to do something not
only unconstitutional but illegal
mike pence did not have the authority to
overturn the election
and yes he would be charged
with a federal crime absolutely that's
why mark short is so [ __ ] pissed off
at republicans
that's why he's pissed off at him i'm no
fan of mark short by any stretch of the
imagination
me and him would could talk for days and
days and not agree on a [ __ ]
thing
i mean besides that matt gatz is
probably gonna go to prison
for sex trafficking we showed that video
yesterday but mark short the chief of
staff of the vice president united
states who was the target to be killed
if he didn't do what donald trump wanted
him to do
and he's also the target in the eastman
memo and the plan of illegally
overturning our vote
which is a delusional plan at best
at best it was delusional that mike
pence could somehow swing a gavel and
crown donald trump king
it really [ __ ] stupid
really [ __ ] dumb the votes were
already certified the vote was legal
biden was already the president-elect
there's nothing that congress could do
to stop it they could protest that's all
that is it's just a pro and the ability
to protest
but they did more than protest they
tried to use the protest to overturn and
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup and
the coup attempt is still ongoing and
their attempt this time is not a violent
coup their attempt this time is to take
over governments anywhere and anyhow
they can that way they can get inside
the government and tear it apart
and take your democracy away from you
take away your way of life
do you really want a bunch of white
christian nationals self-proclaimed
white christian nationalist overt nazis
jesus christ there were people marching
outside that the student conference the
turning points usa student conference in
florida with nazi flags
they're nazis and charlie kirk is gonna
sue now the view i guess in whoopi
goldberg because she called him a nazi
well hey charlie while you're handing
out cease and desist send one here to
the tony michaels podcast [ __ ]
you're a nazi you're a [ __ ] nazi and
anyone who is there in support of you is
also a [ __ ] nazi
there was nazis outside with the [ __ ]
flags
stop pretending like you people aren't
encouraging these [ __ ]
it's enough of this garbage call it what
it is charlie kirk's a nazi marjorie
taylor green lauren bobert matt gatz
anyone who supports the turning points
usa conference that they had nazis
your [ __ ] fascist nazis
and i applaud
the view and anyone who else who will
join me in calling them nazis so charlie
kirk have your lawyer
get your lawyer some [ __ ] money and
have them send me one here
just just dm me i'll send you the
[ __ ] address to send it to
let's do that
you
fascist piece of [ __ ]
that's what we have to focus on and we
have oh we have some races that we have
to focus on here it looks like there's a
development this morning in the race to
defeat ron johnson that russian putin's
puppet asset that's right ron johnson
the guy who went to russia and and got
his knee pads on for
for putin
that on the fourth of july of all of
other holidays out there
independence day our day of freedom he
went and
gave fellatio to
hypothetic you know not you know not i
mean he may have actually given i don't
know maybe that's what putin is holding
above him i don't know it's hard to tell
with ron johnson it's hard to tell
but the case and ron johnson uh the the
uh
one of the owners of
uh the milwaukee are excuse me
well um
let's see
who is this
and they dropped out of the race yes
alex
uh
larsey or lozie lar lazuri lazary alex
lazary has dropped out of the race
giving the the nomination of the
democratic ticket to the favorite to win
which only strengthens the possibility
that ron johnson will lose his seat
there you go boom there's another seat
you want to make joe manchin irrelevant
again
i want to make joe manchin irrelevant
again it's to win these races or win
these senate races
georgia
ohio pennsylvania arizona missouri
missouri is in play folks that missouri
race is in play
i think there's a sleeper candidate in
missouri that could be a senator
we may walk into
the 2022 mid to after the 2022 midterms
of 54 democrats in the united states
senate which makes joe manchin
and kirsten cinema almost exactly
irrelevant
you will no longer see their names in
the news
they will not be able to stall anything
or [ __ ] around they'll be able to
yell and scream but that's about it
so it's time for you the people the
voters to engage in the ballot
whatever whatever it takes whatever
whatever you're good at whether you're
good at talking on the phone or texting
or writing letters or sending postcards
you can do all that if you got some
extra change in your pocket these
campaigns are going to need some [ __ ]
money
to win and to make sure we beat back
trumpism in this country
this
christian white nationalism
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous that we in
2022
we have to try to fend off a bunch of
overt nazis
it's ridiculous but that's just the way
it is and that's the way it's gonna be
this year
so stop trying to [ __ ] focus on
whether donald trump is gonna be
investigated or indicted or not indict
him in the court of public opinion you
as the prosecutor in 2022
and let's hand him his conviction and
his allies and the people who still love
him and stu and still grovel at his feet
let's hand them their conviction in the
2022 midterm
that's your jury selection that's your
jury
vote look at it that way
that the 2022 midterm is the jury vote
for convicting donald trump and his
allies
in the court of public opinion
because at the end of the day right now
in this year in our democracy that is
the only thing that matters
now rather the department of justice
moves on charges or not we're going to
find out they will
but again they cannot swing and miss
they have to connect on these charges
they can not swing and miss
it our democracy depends on them
connecting if they decide the charge and
who they decide to charge that that is
the the cold hard truth
so as the news breaks again no [ __ ]
sherlock
as the news breaks
that of course the department of justice
investigating donald trump
for the crimes that were committed at
january 6
of course they were
we can stop listening to the [ __ ]
you can stop listening to it you don't
have to listen to it anymore you don't
have to play along or [ __ ] do any
that kind of nonsense
let's convict
donald trump and his allies anyone who
supports him and trumpism and maga
in the 2022 midterm we are the jury we
have the jury vote
speaking of white christian nationalism
we talk about that in today's interview
today i have a great interview for you
dakota von adams the estranged son of
stuart rhodes
joins me today in an interview talking
about day eight of the hearings what he
took away from day eight
and what he see
what he sees as
um
the oath keepers and stewart rhodes and
some of these trials moving forward
as we talk about the department of
justice but he also responds to stuart
rhodes giving an interview
to the gateway pundit
jesus christ again that's a whole other
ball of wax
when you have stuart rhodes making
jailhouse calls to the gateway pundit
sending signals out into the world
he gave a recent interview saying he was
going to sue the sex select committee
and benny thompson remember just a week
ago or a couple weeks ago he was so
excited so excited to go testify in
front of cameras in an open mic oh yeah
he loved the select committee then
absolutely [ __ ] loved it
but now he's gonna sue him because they
wouldn't let him gap in front of a
microphone i guess i don't [ __ ] know
he says it's because they called him a
white nationalist
well listen
if there are 10 people and i said this
yesterday if there are 10 people sitting
at a table having dinner with one nazi
one
you have 11 nazis at that table
mark it down write that [ __ ] down
if you have 10 people having dinner at a
table with one nazi just one you have 11
nazis at that table
and stuart rhodes to claim that he
didn't
his group didn't have white nationalism
give me a [ __ ] break
give me a break
you met you met with enrique tario the
leader of one of the biggest
white nationalist
public groups in the country the proud
boys the day before to hand off the
security forces
for roger stone give me a [ __ ] break
stupid roads so we're gonna watch dakota
break that down
uh today we just have a long discussion
about that
and i in the in the front of the
interview i could have edited it but in
the front of the interview um
i i i have a long pause so
so pay attention i actually um dakota
has become
a a great
asset here to the tony michaels podcast
for everything that is oath keepers
proud boys and militia and white
nationalists
and even the deep dark web the far right
um infiltrating like 4chan 8-chan and
some of these other
these other deep dark parts of the web
he's he's experienced it in his life he
knows exactly what it is because he's
had his eyeballs on it for years and
years he grew up in the militia movement
so i i feel like he's a brilliant mind
and a great uh asset to the country to
actually look at and know exactly what
is happening before us through the
periscope
of people who follow these movements
that is the most important part
that dakota does is that he actually
looks through the lens of people who
follow and grow up and are cultivated
and groomed in these militia movements
these white nationalist movements
and how to pick a picket apart
we also talk about the new world order
that's right the new world order we talk
about it in the end of the interview so
stick around for this interview
you're definitely not going to want to
miss this interview with dakota is a
great interview he's getting better and
better and better
at these interviews and the information
that he has is so valuable again looking
through the lens
of the white nationalist movement the
militia movements themselves to pick
apart and tell you pro-democracy people
what these people think how they think
what they think where they're moving
towards
what all this stuff means because
sometimes it's almost like it's in code
it's almost like it's in code and we
talk about that in the interview as well
so stick around for that after the at
the bottom of the hour after break go
ahead and subscribe to the tony michaels
podcast right here on youtube you know
we come every single weekday we come to
you
at youtube twitter and twitch at noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific for two
full hours every single weekday monday
through friday we also simulcast from
the midas touch facebook page
so don't forget to subscribe today is
wednesday so for you new audience
members tomorrow is thursday and we do a
poll
for the bone end of the week so don't
forget to follow us on twitter at the
tony michael's pod where you can vote
for bonehead of the week tomorrow and
boy a lot of hens are sure to make
themselves known
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
play this interview it's about an hour
long
uh with dakota and then once the
interview is over and we come back from
the break we will go through the [ __ ]
list roundup i have a lot of video i
want to show you guys
there's candidates out there and con
sitting congress people out there
embracing white christian nationalism
that's what you should call it by the
way
white christian nationalism when they're
talking about this don't let them get
away with just leaving off the white
part white christian nationalism
stick around through the break the
interview with dakota von adams right
after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you
crying in pain because they have to live
under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us through the break
we have our regular guest
dakota von adams our our our regular
white nationalist
uh
right well we're going to talk about uh
the word white nationalist uh later on
in the interview uh when it comes to
stuart giving a
uh a jailhouse interview to none other
than the gateway pundit
which is another story in and of itself
but you you have become on the show the
oath keepers proud boys and white
nationalist groups and a really militia
expert here for us at the tony michael
podcast i didn't mean to pause so long
dakota yeah i'm just uh coming at you
live
from the podcast shed
great great yeah what your you're you're
streaming now you're doing some of your
own content so that's great so we'll
we'll do a shameless plug later on so
everyone stick around through this
interview that way you know where to
find
kill my sub stack yeah exactly exactly
you can you can pimp your pimp your
content here on the on the show so let
me start because i know
as soon as the hearing was over just i
think it was about an hour afterwards
you messaged me said hey i have a lot to
say
um so let's start with the hearing the
the the last hearing that we saw which
is number eight
in in the season one finale as it were
what's the dog's name by the way
this is mocha she's very big say hello
okay yeah well the audience loves the
the animals the audience loves animals
so um
maybe mocha will help us do this hearing
uh talk back and forth so what did you
make of the hearing what things stood
out to you the most because i know
you were talking earlier about um
some people were making comments about
it but you had a certain thought about
it what
what was your take from the la the last
hearings the season finale as it were
my take from the season finale is it
definitely feels like a pre-planned
produced season finale this feels like
when like i've said before when you are
writing an essay
where you're trying to get a point
across the general public you start out
by telling them what you're going to
tell them you tell them and then you
tell them what you told them this
episode the eighth session was the
summary episode it's the one
that is the penultimate edited together
concise one-stop timeline
for you to show your relatives and
friends and associates who might have
absorbed all the lies about the january
6 insurrection
definitively with video evidence and
direct visual aids
uh discrediting all of that and showing
the truth this is where they throw in
all the meme footage which is very very
smart they get josh hawley skadoodling
for his life they get
uh trump's bloopers and outtakes
they get discovery channel special mode
where we get the 3d model of the white
house to demonstrate exactly how short
the walk would have been for trump to go
to his briefing room and talk the mob
down at any time juxtaposed with
edited in on the little 3d rendered tv
screen in the oval in the uh not the
oval office the presidential dining room
the live fox news covers that he would
have been watching at that exact moment
and
showing that simultaneously with
uh
testimony of secret service members
relaying last messages to their families
because they thought they were about to
die
in combat with the january 6-inch
insurrectionist to try to protect mike
pence from a lynch mob
that
all put together with kenzinger on fire
with
cheney going after bill barr
with the pro-trump
uh
extraordinarily trumpy
witnesses who were proud of their work
with his administration
who turned on him because of january 6th
this is the
pulling the wool from your one kind of
smart uncle's eyes episode that's what
it's for and i think it does an
excellent job of that so for people who
already know all of it and this is all
old familiar ground it's not going to
add a lot new
for
showing clips
or showing a single episode that is
highly entertaining
and well edited so it keeps your
interest to somebody that you know who
might be reached
or has absorbed wrong information but
isn't clinging to what is part of its
identity this is it this is this is
the weapon that's been handed to you by
the january 6 committee
well i i can't agree with you more on
that on that point
and a couple things too that i'd like to
add now the the
the story where they're telling from the
dining room when uh kevin mccarthy
actually was able to get on the phone
with donald trump the president united
states at that time and his first
instinct his first instinct dakota which
i almost thought of you immediately is
when the president united states like oh
it's antifa right that's it that was the
first instinct that donald trump had to
blame
blame the entire thing on antipa it was
it was almost like he was a pepe the
frog internet troll right in my thread
like oh antifa and and
but kevin mccarthy said no no they're
maki my staff is running away and
they're your supporters they're the ones
that were down there listening to you
and then he said and they he immediately
immediately in this thread that we are
listening to right he immediately
changes his mind that this is no longer
antifa it is his supporters you are
correct mr mccarthy but you must not
love your country and you must not love
me as much as they do that's the problem
like
he totally [ __ ] him on the antifa
narrative and then he completely does a
180 and then says well here's the reason
why i i don't know that moment in and of
itself really kind of describes
not just the mindset
of trump himself but it really does show
that the tail is wagging the dog right
like that is
that trump didn't invent that response
that everything's antifa
he is he's seen this response and he's a
copycat right don't you think
yep and it uh all it did was confuse the
messaging where they could have stuck to
one consistent narrative it was all
antifa
and burned everybody who was on the
ground and then pretended everything was
fake or they could have stuck with these
were patriots this was a legitimate
action to protest a stolen election
which is becoming a standard gop party
line
and ashley babbitt was a martyr
but they tried to do both because of
confused messaging
from
trump's insiders that started
immediately as they tried to grapple
internet trends and go with what was
most popular and while that worked out
pretty well in the past it
in this case
muddied and confused their narrative and
i think it's hurt them more than it's
helped
i think you're right the other the other
significant thing
um with the witnesses because you
brought up the witnesses we we saw
a former national security council
advisor a lifelong republican even try
even tried during his testimony to to
kind of it was kind of gross right he
it was
disgusting to righteousness
to make trump into this great presidency
right it was real it really was [ __ ]
vile
that the witness was doing that but i
think it was important to show that this
is not some [ __ ] left-wing
lib [ __ ] right that's not what this
that's not who he was he was a trumper
and but even he was so disgusted that
day
watching dereliction of duty and donald
trump doing nothing so that way he could
actually become the king of the united
states or moga whatever the hell he
actually whatever his aim was here i
think that's the actual thing we didn't
get is what his aim was but i don't know
if we'll ever know that you know
short-sighted grasp on power i can give
you my personal theory which is
constructed almost entirely from
certain similarities and psychological
profile between uh my father stuart
rhodes and donald trump because they're
both malignant narcissists
when stewart
founded oath keepers from that point on
his future was set because once he had a
taste of being the old hebrews militia
general and the attention
and the respect from uh men who were a
lot better at him in a lot of a lot
better than him in a lot of ways
objectively
and the money and the little amount of
work that he could do in the adoration
uh
he could never ever go back to
regular life after that you could never
go back to work even working as a lawyer
and flubbing his way through the workday
doing jackal or
working for a political activist group
from then on
only the level of adoration that being a
militia general and savior of america
would get him
would be enough and only the easy
lifestyle that that brought him would be
enough
i
subscribe to the theory that trump
didn't really intend to win the election
and now that it is inner circle that he
was going to parlay it into
his own media channel and rule right
wing talk forever
uh off of the
off of the energy of the election was
stolen from me and make that the new
birth or conspiracy for the entire
clinton presidency i believe that was
plan a that's pretty well known at this
point a lot of people think that
once he was in
trump's ability to be anything but the
president was ruined because that he was
addicted within the first hit
of presidential respect and power and
he
regardless even of
the fact that he
was likely headed to prison if he lost
power
he was psychologically incapable of
giving up powers an authoritarian
personality they don't relinquish
control once they have it he could never
again step back down to a position of
any less importance than the president
which is why he has maintained remained
effectively present in his own mind
and
is insisting on the stolen election
and playing to his crowd all through the
united states i think presently
the plan as it is has been to run a
weird quantum
will he won't he political campaign
that
as a side benefit screws over all of his
rivals within the republican party who
could one day steal his mojo and to burn
the gop for failing to be 100 behind him
during the election fraud and the coup
attempt
and also i believe just to grift money
so that he can flee the country
that's probably the conscious plan but
subconsciously
trump is never going to be able to
accept
losing
and
just leave quietly to be putin's pet
president in exile which is one of the
possibilities that i was thinking about
in january of 2020
he's not going to be able to do it he's
going to be compelled within himself to
try again because he will never be able
to let go
of the idea of him as the most important
special man in the world
i think you're right because he does he
does have this complex right and it is
that it is that authoritarian complex
but more than anything is this selfish
need to uh advance his ego right now
you know speaking of of the witnesses
matthew pottinger as we uh referred to
him before there was also uh sarah
matthews she was the former deputy white
house uh press secretary
a very young lady this almost kind of
this the same story that we
see working her way up through the
administration as cassidy hutchinson now
cassidy hutchinson was in the chief of
staff's office now sarah matthews in the
press secretary's office but what i
found
um
really telling one of the moments where
she's describing
trying to get through these people's
skulls of how
gross it was for them to be doing
nothing and watching as our democracy
was trying to be overtaken
by these this band of maga idiots right
was under attack by a cult of physical
attack by a kind of personality who
would accept nothing but their dear
leader right and and and and for no
reason other than he is their leader and
and the moment where she's describing
if we can't we can't have him admit
because we don't want to look like we're
losing we don't want to lose the
narrative and she she she thrust her
hand up towards the tv she says and she
says does it look like we're [ __ ]
winning like what what do you think this
looks like and really i think going back
to your first statements on the hearing
itself
i think that's the biggest challenge is
getting some of this stuff
in front of
some of these people who still either
don't know what happened on january 6
because i still think there's
you know not maybe not a large
percentage but there's a large number of
people and they vote in this country i
think it's a large percentage i think
it's the majority of my town at least
the majority of the guys that i run into
on construction sites or in local
emergency services even who genuinely
don't know what happened on the six and
they've simply absorbed the
media presented to them by fox news and
newsmax
right whatever whatever that narrative
was it was a nothing burger right they
have no clue what actually happened um
but some of these bites these sound
bites can really work their way through
like you were saying at some of the
previous hearings we saw the the ketchup
story where he was throwing ketchup
against the wall we saw the story about
the secret service having a scuffle
inside the the the presidential mark
motorcade which those two stories in and
of itself really don't speak to the the
crime of a coup exactly they don't have
a lot of bearing
um on
criminal evidence
except in like what they're related to
obviously trump trying to get the secret
service to take him to the capitol is uh
circumstantial evidence that he was
involved with the mob going up the steps
because he wanted to lead them
but much more importantly
throwing the burger and throwing the
ketchup and trying to choke a secret
service agent
um and wrestling back and forth over the
headrest in the presidential armored suv
that is
a memeable image
that will spread and become a running
joke it's the kind of messaging
that
democrats and liberals in the left have
been nearly incapable of
for decades
it's the kind of thing where like the
federalist is now atta is trying to
attack the january 6 committee for
uh
hiring tv producers from abc at all
when the reality is they're terrified
that the opposition has finally caught
on
to their method
absolutely well and we and we
we
witness this with the tape of the
outtakes like you brought up earlier
because we we knew there were outtakes
right and and some some folks and i even
thought that it was gonna be outtakes
from the original message from the rose
garden where he says you know you're
good people i love you you know really
stroking stroking this whole
again the tail wagging the dog because
he can't go against his people because
he really truly has stuck to that
principle that i can't go against putin
and i can't go against my supporters
like if i if i start to do those two
things i'll lose control i'll lose power
and but in the statement the outtakes
that i thought were so significant and
everyone watched
were the outtakes from the statement of
january 7th and i think why it's so
significant is not exactly what he says
but him throwing the face
that's right him throwing a fit about
what he refuses to say right and then
how he was marking out these things he
can't say that he can't because
the tail won't wag me if i say those
things right they'll abandon me and
that's why he's stopped taking credit
for the vaccine entirely he
tested that out and crowd work at his
rallies
didn't play well and he dropped it
forever right right because because he
he knew that that was not something that
they would wag the tail or the tail
would wag the dog with they wouldn't
play that game right so it's always him
trying to get the tail to wag the dog
right that's all it is is because he's
always playing tonight and steve bannon
does this really well too um and you
know this with the deep dart you know
4chan 8-chan and how he's the pied piper
of these trolls out there and now donald
trump has four [ __ ] shirts and his
weeping skin
which i'm sure we'll get to steve bannon
here in a little bit when we get to the
part that the actual season finale
didn't show
um because we talked about this
beforehand off camera
the one thing that really didn't give us
the satisfaction
um we got a lot of satisfaction out of
the holly video which we'll talk about
here in a second but the thing we didn't
get satisfaction from and we thought we
might see
is the thing me and you have talked
about a lot and and
it exists we know it exists we know the
committee knows that it exists and they
know the back channel that is there and
the back channel between stuart rhodes
and the actual orders for that qrf the
weapons that are were stored across the
potomac
and the prezi united states we did not
hear or
any kind of hint at all
of who and what that back channel was
the day of the fifth and the day of the
six
we we didn't get any kind of
satisfaction there so why do you think
that is
i think that's because uh
the january 6 committee and the
department of justice are working
towards overlapping but not quite
unanimous purposes the january 6
committee is
racing the clock to get
the entire story presented in an
entertaining format with
clips and visual aids in front of the
american people before the elections so
that everyone understands what's at
stake ahead of the midterms
running under the gun to put together
everything that you and i and probably a
good portion of your audience already
knows in a concise one-stop playlist
or broadcast that everyone can look at
to get fully caught up or close to it
the department of justice is i believe
approaching this like a mob
investigation working their way up the
chain building a bulletproof case
because if they swing at trump it has to
connect
and so we get the department of justice
in many cases running out ahead
of the publicly visible work the
department of justice is doing i mean
the committee running out ahead of the
department of justice
at least in their public work
and where we see a weird gap where we've
had the leaks before we know
that stewart was stewart and tario were
in the friends of stone group chat it
was seen reporting that they have that
group chat we
have heard the reports of stuart on the
phone with a mysterious intermediary
who might have been able to put him in
touch with trump but refused to on the
night of the six when it was clear that
the coup had not worked and was being
abandoned for now
and the committee didn't address that
the committee didn't even really address
oath keepers except for
uh the disgusting walkie-talkie um
audio log intercepts and the reason for
that i think is because that is
something the department of justice is
pursuing heavily because if they have
hard evidence of those connections
the chain of command from trump to roger
stone michael flynn down to proud boys
and oath keepers for the paramilitary
operation happening under cover of the
mob
that is the smoking gun for bringing
trump and his inner circle up on serious
charges
and the notable absence of
any mention of it
in
the public hearings
in season one
i think is an indicator that that's
being pursued very aggressively and it's
being taken very seriously especially
now as we're seeing that the department
of justice has issued
a large number of grand jury subpoenas
related to the fake elector slates
they're
they're going after
the prongs
of this coup attempt and there is no way
that they're overlooking the
paramilitary operation especially with
the looming oath keepers and proud boys
seditious conspiracy trials
well i think um your your suggestion
that doj is moving towards an up the
ladder to a bigger fish you know that's
what the
prosecutors use the language big fish
small fish and i think they're getting
bigger bigger fish in front of the grand
jury because we know march there's
reports that mark short who is the vice
president our former vice president mike
pence's chief of staff who was with him
in the parking garage when they wouldn't
go with secret service i have different
feelings on that um now than i did
before the hearings but we can we can
leave that for another day i want to get
back to because you brought up the the
radio chatter because we're kind of
talking about the back channel and that
radio chatter between the oath keepers
so
do i i mean
you were around stuart you were around
these militia groups your entire life
was it pretty common to have a back
channel in different um chains of
command or tell us about that this is
qrf tell us about how that would
actually work and what the protocol
would be
well the anything large scale happens in
the militia movement is
a weird fractious coalition of different
disparate groups and little factions
everybody's got a tiny fiefdom
and
what we're hearing there is
like it's strangely familiar to me the
way they're talking about it is they
have their mission
there undergoing it their
um but they're keeping one eye on what
the president is saying publicly with
his tweets in case it means a mission
scrub that's why when he says uh don't
attack capitol police the one guy is
like oh he didn't say anything about not
attacking congress people
so
what do you mean what do you mean by
mission scrub describe describe what
that means in in in simple terms what if
trump had called it off publicly said
everyone stop
go home
and if they'd continue them attempting
their mission at that point they would
no longer have had the cover of the mob
to operate within it would have just
been them
and it it's the uh their mission which i
believe was
abducting nancy pelosi or other senators
and seizing
the boxes with the electoral votes to
create a delay in the certification
process that could be exploited
that would not have been possible
without the coverage of thousands of
violent trump supporters
and trump could have called off those
thousands of supporters
in one broadcast or one tweet it
wouldn't have even taken walking to the
briefing room could have done it from
his phone any time so they're seeing
these tweets pop up they're going yeah
he hasn't told everyone to back off yet
we're still a go and they're laughing
about it so what you're so
so what you're hearing in that in that
radio chatter
is
that um
they're taking what trump is saying or
what more maybe more importantly what
he's not saying
as orders is that kind of what you're
saying yes
so yeah so so if
if let's let's just play out a scenario
here because we don't again we don't
know who that back channel was and if we
do know that stewart rhodes was maybe
desperate to contact the president
united states where did where did the
fallout happen you think in the timeline
in that 187 minutes when stewart and the
oath keepers had no idea what the
mission was anymore right they had no
idea what their orders were were we
still going forward where do you think
it fell apart for them was it when the
national guard shows up because mike
pence kind of forced the issue and
donald trump had to have the national
guard come in is that where you think it
was or where do you think it is in that
187 minutes i think
um it's whatever point it is where
the momentum stalls and they do not
get their hands on the senders it's
becoming clear that they're not making
any further progress towards their
strategic goals and there's just
a mob milling about causing property
damage
in the capital it's when stewart is
getting repeated messages from the qrf
guy asking if they're going in
and he's saying not yet
it's that it's then it's this it's in
that span
in the slow moving uh grinding to a halt
of their momentum
when
the tide starts to turn
and they're no longer progressing
towards their goals and then you hear
that the national guard is coming and
then trump tells everybody we love you
go home and it's like oh [ __ ] i guess
it's vietcong tunnels in kentucky now
right so so it goes from in and maybe in
maybe the oath keeper's mind the
leadership to mine stewart's mind it
goes from hey we are going to actually
be able to do an insurrection here uh
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup which
i that's what i call it um it goes from
that to him seeing it as oh well damn
this is just a riot now right they're
gonna call and they're going to call in
the riot police they're going to call
the right off they're going to pull it
off and now it's just a riot we don't
have the cover anymore
to actually commit an insurrection
rather it's to um take the the actual
valid state electors and switch them
with the sh you know the ones that
that's the continuing the continuing
eastman memo plan which stewart was not
a pivotal player in
from anything that i've seen and that is
why i think we have that report of
stewart on the phone with his
intermediary
uh begging him to put trump on
and begging him to
influence trump to call up oath keepers
and militias
uh and deputize them
to
seize control of the capital and
reinstate them to the presidency and
this is kind of the martial law
the martial law insurrection act right
this is yeah that's where
it kind of has this in his brain which
is which is uh really flooring from the
stories that you've told before about
the oath keepers in his mission because
that's the actual opposite of what yeah
oath keepers
it's in the founding 10 orders we will
not obey is uh
martial law
and the suspension of the constitution
is never ever okay and always to be
opposed
and the complete 180 degree flip on that
is just a signal of
stewart placing his personal loyalty in
trump rather than his oath to the
constitution and that it was all a lie
and
but don't you think that this goes back
to that authoritarian power is that that
stuart
was terrified of a bite administration
of abiding doj and you know he's he's
paranoid still about the bundy ranch and
what happened there and um i mean
some of that comes into play where it's
maybe not even as much about trump as it
is about stewart you think it absolutely
was just about stuart because his
um he clung to trump for his own safety
he clung to trump because clinging to
maga was the path of least resistance
for continued relevance of oath keepers
and for making money
it was and he
especially whenever he got plugged in
with that intermediary
it became an opportunity to make oath
keepers into something very important
in the coming order
when trump would cement his control over
the united states
uh
placing do you think stewart rhodes had
i just want to play play a game here
real quick so you think oh harry rhodes
head like this fantasy that donald trump
becomes the king of the united states
the constitution is no more which means
trump can basically
crown him the general the uh
commander-in-chief as it were type thing
that you see in a lot of autocracy
because a lot of autocracies the king is
not actually the head of the the
military they're not the
commander-in-chief they they pass that
on that's too much [ __ ] work right a
king wants to you know do different
things than than worry about what the
military do you think that some some
sick twisted
you know reality that stuart rhodes
thought that's what was going to happen
absolutely
absolutely i think he was gunning for
being the head of trump's internal
security division he wanted to be the
head of
trump's revolutionary guard or a
republican guard to pull from
contemporary examples
and if the coup had gone off i would
have been able to foresee an eventual
power struggle where stewart would have
attempted to oust
eric prince or michael flynn
uh whichever one ended up in charge of
trump's loyal military
um yeah okay this is the right-hand man
i i am i am regretting going down this
imaginary road already it's um we would
we would be in canada and i would be
forming a
a dark mirror of all the militia groups
on the uh the ones that watch the
southern border and patrol to catch to
catch drug mules and they're full of
nazis
i would have been forming my anti-oath
keepers uh militia border recon right
with this with the back with the backing
of uh
canadian intelligence services for
whenever they wanted people just shot
without having to arrest or turn them
over
it sounds like you've been on secret
meetings with the uh canadian uh
intelligent forces so
but
but but here's the thing back to
stuart rhodes and this back channel and
um why it is so important in that 187
minutes is because stewart rhodes
actually
um and rather it's because
this coup attempt was done by a bunch of
buffoons or not
stewart wasn't let in on the plan
obviously of what the actual plan was
because i actually don't think that
there was an one strategic actual plan i
think that's the other thing that the
hearings have shown us is that
trump was willing to do whatever it took
it didn't matter which avenue he didn't
care if the supreme court made him
president he didn't care if the if the
oath keepers and the proud boys and a
bunch of white nationalists
went and committed violence and made him
president they saved him saved him
or or if
whatever the case the state electors the
state legislators the courts the doj
whoever would just make him president
that's what he would have went with he
didn't give a [ __ ] it was it didn't he
didn't have one strategic plan it was
like we'll just throw spaghetti at the
wall and see how much
fractured chain of command and one thing
that i think is clearly demonstrated by
that audio log
of the walkie-talkie communications from
the oath keepers stack
that made entry and from the signal
chats and that we have
where uh stuart is talk is in
communication with his group and the qrf
is once the day started going once
january 6 went underway
um there was no direct communication
with stewart's handlers higher up the
chain
uh whoever he was reporting to that
brought him in on the overall plan they
did not have direct communication
probably for security reasons for the
only smart thing that they did
in the sense of avoiding criminal
prosecution
but it also undermines the chances of
their operation being successful because
now
when they're fully committed on the six
and when the stack and the proud boys
are leaving the crowd early to show up
at the capitol and get ready to force
entry
they have to go off of inferring [ __ ]
from trump's public statements instead
of getting
a call on a burner phone
from their handle or relaying direct
orders
the they have to
go off of a guessing game
and then when things go off plan they
don't know what's happening
further up ahead and that falls apart
and that
that uh cutting off of communications i
think is demonstrated by this by the
uncertainty by the having to interpret
from trump's public statements what
their orders are
um that shows that their go between
was willing to
keep
ties
separate and hidden
to protect themselves from prosecution
if the coup didn't work out on the
paramilitary aspect
even at the expense of undermining the
success of the paramilitary operation
those guys can fall back on the eastman
plan
and if oath keepers and proud boys don't
deliver then they just get burned right
right well and and that
um goes back to
like you said this chain of command
being broken um because there really
wasn't one in that trump didn't want a
chain of command because he doesn't want
to be connected to the oath keepers or
the proud boys and the reason why is
because they're white nationalists
they're white nationalists and this
brings me to
this
um a gateway pundit uh jailhouse
interview with stuart that was released
i know a couple days ago i guess it's
been um yesterday or the day before go
ahead and dredge it up dredge up the
childhood memories let me hear this
sweet sultry voices of my childhood yes
so this is so this is stewart
talking to
and i'm assuming it's the same gateway
pundit reporter that's been doing these
jailhouse interviews uh and stuart's
kind of been all over the map with these
interviews
if you've listened to any of the audio
from the gateway pundit
um interviews that they put out
this one specifically though
he he really he's got something to say
i i find it funny that last week he was
begging the january 6 select committee
to come in and give his side of the
story in front of the lights and the
cameras in the microphone this week he
wants to sue them because he was hanging
out with a bunch of white nationalists
now for people who don't know
january 5th there is a documentary that
was being made
and stuart rhodes appeared in a parking
garage
with enrique tario who was not supposed
to be in washington dc
that day he was
he was barred from being inside the city
by a judge because of a rally that
happened weeks before and he burned
a sign in front of a church
and they weren't going to allow him into
the city on the 6th for
obvious reasons
but stuart rhodes my view is
because there was private conversations
that weren't recorded
my view is is that was a passing of the
church because what we what we noticed
the next day is
someone named roger stone who is
possibly that back channel for the qrf
and the orders from the president of the
united states who knows maybe
now or michael flynn would be my two top
rice right because michael flynn we know
has been uh liaison with the proud boys
and the oath keepers both
but it seems like that meeting in the
garage where he's meeting with the white
nationalist group the leader pr proud
boys
um where it's almost like a passing of
the torch like they don't know what's
going on again back to the whole you
know fractured plan fractured chain of
command they have no idea
so they're trying to make the best of
what situation they have without having
direct orders from this back channel
but it seems as if the proud boys
switched the security from them to the
oath keepers which um
those oath keepers are now pleading
guilty and cooperating who are
protecting roger stone which should make
roger stone and stuart rhodes
very very [ __ ] nervous is the way i
see it that's why i've always believed
that roger stone is probably the
likelihood
that he is one of the back channels and
maybe you know as stewart rhodes might
and the oath keepers and the proud boys
might have had a back at plan where they
had uh roger stone and mike flynn i
don't know i don't know if the
department of justice would be able to
actually
smoke that out or not it seems like the
january 6 select committee has evidence
of a back channel and who it is um
chose not to address it for the time
right well and that could be like you
said earlier because the department of
justice doesn't want to ruin a criminal
case against that person or that person
is now cooperating in an effort to move
up the chain uh a little fish big fish
stuff like we talked earlier but let's
go to go ahead anything
that sinks
a conviction
of
stuart rhodes
in connection with this back channel and
especially anything that sinks
his connect
is very bad for donald trump
that provides the clearest stepping
stone to prosecuting trump for january 6
and the most solid
if trump goes down and the evidence in
his trial includes
his secret communications with an
intermediary with the white house
that is the silver bullet so do you
think you know speaking of that and i'm
gonna go to the tape here of the gateway
pundit interview where he's threatening
to sue this sex committee um for calling
him a white nationalist appropriately
but
but
do you think
these gateway pundit interviews more
than anything are stewart road signaling
to donald trump
i think he's signaling to anybody who
will listen he's very much feeling like
he's been let out left out to dry which
he should have expected he knows the
history of how this [ __ ] works he knows
that the brown shirts got purged once
hitler took power you should have seen
it coming you're talking about the essay
yeah
the essay
once they outlived their usefulness the
sa and the
weirdo uh weirdo left-wing uh
factions of the nazi party
got purged and executed and imprisoned
in
uh one in a one night shocking shock and
awe campaign called the light of night
of the long knives and stuart has ranted
about that at length
in all throughout my childhoods he
should have seen it coming and he should
have known from trump's personal history
that if he failed to deliver
he would just be blamed for failing
trump
and would be left hanging
and now he's shouting for anybody who
will listen and trying to remain
relevant
so let's listen to him
yeah let's listen to the shouting from
from the
the uh the jailhouse phone let's listen
for your uh members to uh
to press charges if they feel that
that's something they want to do against
uh this blast for me
they can sue him because they can sue
jesus
and also benny thompson has made
statements calling oath keepers a white
supremacist organization
or white nationalist in the media he did
that along with the president of the
naacp unfortunately right and so they're
not just saying inside the hall of
congress is singing out of the media
which makes them vulnerable to being
sued so they can be super defamation for
sure so one thing about free so so um
for people who don't know because we do
have an interview with you and your mom
tasha um who
has said in the past that
the
founding tenements of
the oath keepers and stewart tried to
keep white nationalists at one point he
actually would go to an extent to purge
white nationalists that would
even give any kind of hint
of racism white nationalism kkk
um you know on
the social media he would purge them
from the oath keepers
but he walked away from that as trump
came to power and obviously he met with
tario before the sixth um who is the
leader of a white nationalist group who
don't pick bones about it so why do you
why do you think stuart here is do you
think he's just crying into his spilled
milk here
he
really really wants his supporters to
take action that will protect him from
further damaging testimony by the
committee that personally hurts him and
oath keepers
he would very much really wants personal
revenge on tatango for speaking out
against him is
what i would say
and he's desperately trying to maintain
the separation between oath keepers and
white nationalists that protected oath
keepers throughout most of his career
now this is something that i covered
a bit in uh my latest piece of writing
but
uh stewart not only obsessed over
uh whether posters on
like websites like stormfront the
holocaust denial center
and white pride website that
uh from posters who were saying that
they were oath keepers members and
trying to infiltrate he obsessed over it
and he saw white nationals infiltration
of oath keepers as a deadly threat
because it would mean that oath keepers
members
would be stripped of security clearances
for
being in an organization that accepted
uh racists or felons
and would taint them in the eyes of the
media because for a while he was trying
to make oath keepers into a legitimate
organization
on a national scale
or using that whatever legitimacy he had
as cover
and
while this was going on behind the
scenes
he would maintain ties with figures like
chuck baldwin and matt shea who have
deep connections to
the white nationalist christian identity
movement
and
accepted that so there was always a
practical willingness
to be friends of friends with white
nationalists
as long as he kept it on the down low
and in his desperation
to
hide behind trump's skirts and also to
use trump as a ladder towards his own
power and relevance
uh stewart became more willing to accept
ties
with
neo-nazis and white nationalists under
the great trump umbrella
and where previously he kicked out
everyone who went to charlottesville
which is brings us back to tattenhofe in
one of his interviews uh tottenham
remains silent while a tv show host
is
uh talking about oathkeepers and
charlottesville and
for weeks stewart had been losing it
over charlottesville and was demanding
that nobody goes to charlottesville if
any of you idiots insist on going to
charlottesville you are not bringing
your oath keepers apparel or merchandise
with you or you are banned for life and
some guys did anyway
and got photographed wearing oath
keepers shirts and that is what got oath
keepers kicked off of paypal
and
tattenhove would have been absolutely
still in the loop at this point but the
timeline that he testified to publicly
in previous interviews says that he cut
ties fully
sometime before that so he couldn't
really express an opinion on it on the
entire fiasco and the internal schism
that happened with this purging of
members from the roles over attending or
supporting
charlottesville and damaging the
organization
i think irreparably
as a result
now
that said well i'm not the
world's biggest fan of tattoo and
probably never will be for my own
reasons
tattenhove going and giving those
interviews and
especially his work on his colorado
switchblade newsletter where he's been
talking
in very plain terms about
every
uh everything the gop is trying to pull
off right now
he's doing good work he's telling the
truth he's getting
an important message out there
so right now he is absolutely working on
the side of good
but
that
bit about charlottesville
is
again just a little bit of
where he could
have taken the opportunity
to
spread a little bit of knowledge about
how the exact interplay between oath
keepers and the charlottesville protest
worked and the decline of oath keepers
and shows not to because he's trying to
downplay how long he was still involved
well and and that dating hove may be
doing the same thing that stewart is
doing here where he's saying oath
keepers should sue that's like committee
and benny thompson for calling them uh
white nationalists now here's the thing
because you know you mentioned the gop
as a whole and the direction the gop and
and the actual alarm that tatinho jason
montano set off during that hearing that
he was in and he's still doing with some
of his work
is that it's not just the oath keepers
it's not just the proud boys it's not
these white nationalist groups
they are inside one political party and
we only have a two-party system here in
this country and he was trying to sound
the alarm because
stewart's
stuart's case
that
that benny thompson calling
oath keepers white nationalists is what
kind of like inflammatory harm has been
done that hasn't already been done well
but anybody else
is appealing to right now would be
turned off by them calling being called
white nationalists by benny thompson
they would take it as a selling point
well think about it we have we have
marjorie taylor green and lauren bobert
who who embraces nationalists well
they're christian white nationalists
they're even a step further towards
nazis but listen the the the actual gop
is embracing nationalism and not just
nationals but christian white
nationalism and and they're begging
they're begging for anyone to pardon
stewart and the rest of the january 6th
select insurrectionist and if that isn't
white nationalism white christian
national whatever they want to build it
as and call it whatever they want
christian nationalism white national
whatever they want to do what however
the hell they want to you know because
they do this a lot
we talked about this before is they go
with one branding like oh that was
really horrible at charlottesville
because some guy took a car and tried to
murder a bunch of people and did kill
somebody and he's convicted now so we
gotta change our name to patriot front
like yeah and we gotta change our
outfits now so we all look similar right
like
we gotta change up our uniform we gotta
rebrand yeah that's right so the
rebranding now is is marjorie taylor
green is not only not only embracing
christian nationalism but she is saying
into a microphone
that hey i'm a proud
she says this i'm a proud christian
nationalist i'm like holy actual [ __ ]
like really you can't get more fascist
than exactly what they're doing and it
no it's always a production wow well
we're about to see it this summer is
victor orban
the
uh great granddaddy of all the
conspiracy theories about his previous
political rival in hungary george soros
one of the architects of the actual vast
right-wing conspiracy new world order
that's been playing
the projecting blame game with all of
its opponents
is going to be speaking at cpac this
year on the heels of a public statement
where he stated and this is the current
head of state of hungary the president
of hungary right stating
pro-putin basically putin's uh pet dog
inside the european union
that uh
nations in which races mix are no longer
really nations and that is why he
opposes hungarians becoming a mismixed
race people and losing hungarianism
and now he's going to be speaking in the
united states at this summer's cpac
well that's not surprising since cpac
took it to to um hungary to have their
little hungarian style fascist
nazi rally there and that's where they
uh just expressed open admiration for
how
uh
orban's uh conservative party
cemented minority rule and has affect
has banned
their political rivals like george soros
from ever being in the country again
and has essentially rigged it so that
very theoretically they could lose an
election but in all practicality it is
impossible so they are just openly
worshipping the man who game planned
what they plan to do in the united
states we all need to pay attention
and we should keep a close eye on uh
victor orban's little visit to the us
so let let's touch on one more thing
before we go because um we talked about
this in private you bro you brought up
the words new world order and the right
wing has always used this as a fear
factor they they use all kinds of things
as fear factors to get people really
riled up and scared about something to
activate their base and especially
violently i think that's a little bit
what donald trump has been doing in his
last rallies is to get his
get unsanctioned violence i think as you
called it in one of our interviews um
but tell us tell the audience about
because we talked about the new world
order privately tell us how
you believe in their quest of convincing
the right wing
uh or or the followers of the right wing
that there is a new world order they
have created one and we see that through
orbon we see that through putin and we
see that in these right-wing um you know
these right-wing pockets throughout the
world it's kind of popular political
groups with intertwined funding with
interlinks between political operatives
the uh
the
slander of george soros and
the
birther conspiracy theory about uh
president barack obama were masterminded
by political advisors who had worked for
urban who came over from hungary to work
for the gop
the links are very clearly there and
what we have
is that all accusations that
liberal democrats leftists socialists
neoliberals anybody who likes the united
nations
and the neoliberal global global order
as it exists today the international
order
or nato or anything else they're all
part of a vast sinister conspiracy to
institute
uh totalitarian rule worldwide and take
your rights away
all the people promoting this
are running in the same
authoritarian populist circles using pop
right-wing populist rhetoric pulling
from the same sources of dark money
and rubbing shoulders continuously in
their efforts to
overthrow democracies and install
authoritarian governments and what that
is starting to look like a lot
is this proud tradition
dating all the way back to hermann
goring
of always accusing your enemy of that
which you do
i am starting to pure projection i'm
starting to believe
that every accusation of the new world
order
has been a confession the entire time it
becomes clear when you look at the deep
ties between orban and the current gop
becomes clear when you look at vladimir
putin's funding for right-wing terrorist
groups the world over and hit ties with
right-wing populist and isolationists in
france and the uk and their meddling and
brexit and the 2016 presidential
election in the united states you even
see russia's involvement with the nra
and tying putin absolutely
you see very clearly uh sexy russian
sexpot handlers
handling in multiple ways uh gop
operatives and nra executives to keep
them on track you know you always have a
way to to uh lightly step over the sex
part you know that you know that you
have the uh you have the ability to do
that i don't have the ability to do that
i just say it she was she was they were
trying to give them handies you know
that's what i would say you said handle
in certain ways but i
you know i don't know
i don't know even uh like
russian escorts who work for the kgp
have standards i would expect that was
just an extended game of whack-a-mole
well it could be it could be and i
didn't mean to interrupt you but but i
think you're right in that the
projection of the new world order
because you you know you probably heard
more about this than i did because i
wasn't a part of the militia movement i
mean it wasn't this new world order
every absolutely everything every that's
where it all comes from everything is
new world order and now that i've become
more aware
i'm tracing back all the propaganda and
the tracing back of all this propaganda
keeps ending up in the same places
even early q anon and the early
conspiracy theories about
uh
hillary clinton's email server wrapped
in george soros somehow like he the
origin point of
george soros being the the militia
movement right wing boogie man dates
back to
the gop getting in bed with
hungarian authoritarians the hungarian
authoritarians are deeply up the asses
of putin's russia
and it's kind of where the competing
brand that we see is
china's belt and road initiative where
china is supporting
just
with no qualms any authoritarian
government
that will sign a deal with them where
they are theoretically communists
but
completely on board with anti-communist
dictatorships that all mutually support
each other across ideological lines
in a self-supporting international
network of desk of despots
and i think
they're that's a competing brand with
what
this global right-wing movement is
attempting to do throughout the western
world
south america and the middle east
because we've seen
faltering attempts at the gop to court
the taliban since their takeover of
afghanistan
and to bring pro-taliban propaganda into
right white supremacist messaging
it's the attempt to assemble
an international league of super evil to
overthrow uh liberal democracy once and
for all
and i think the new world order has
always been projection i think the new
world order has always been right wing
i think i think you're on to something
there and and tell us because i know
you're gonna write about this in your
your your new sub stack and some of the
streams you're doing so tell the
audience before we go
exactly where they can find everything
dakota
pump that shilling pump that showing so
yep i am now it and uh you can get taken
by link tree if you just go to
dakotaviadams.com
um you know and you'll find the link to
my weekly one-hour
weekly wednesday live stream where i do
question answering
and a couple of select youtube videos
and dramatic readings of
right wing media and especially right
wing science fiction that i grew up with
and survivalist training videos and then
also my sub stack
where i
post weekly odd stories from my
childhood that will always forever be
freely available
and
my upcoming series of deprogramming
essays that cover social justice and
political issues
in language that is simple and from an
argument angle that will appeal to your
republican uncle who's a little bit
smart and might be brought around which
is one of my main goals when i started
writing along with that you will get
um
regular hot takes on current events and
reactions to
right wing political rag trends
and
current malicious shenanigans
so go follow dakota
on his sub stack and go check out his
his twitch stream i was there for the
person who was fantastic don't first let
him carry anything no no it was great
very bad no good live stream it was a
great live stream so go to
dakotavadams.com
or file dakota on twitter at dakota v
adams dakota thanks for joining us again
come back thank you for having me on
from the shed
i have nothing else going on in my life
well we'll talk to you soon my friend
have have a great have a great one we'll
talk to you too see you next time
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
what a great another great
[Music]
keepers especially the militia movement
and
white nationalism as it were he's not a
white nationalist he's our white
nationalist expert here on the tony
michaels podcast
i i i paused too soon in the beginning
of the interview so i apologize for that
long pause
but he is he is our he is becoming more
and more of our expert here on the tony
michael's podcast for those types of
topics so i appreciate when dakota joins
us so please do me a favor go over to
dakotavadams.com
and check out all the links over there
to his twitch stream uh to his sub stack
and follow him on twitter as well at
dakota v adams so
dakotavadams.com go to his link tree
you'll find all the links there now
let's help support
dakota in his efforts to write about
the deprogramming
of militia movements and deprogramming
of white nationalism i think it's super
super important and i think the work
that he will do now and in the future is
just as more or more important
than some of the work we do here
and the work that we do here is round up
all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends on a section of the show that you
love best the [ __ ] list roundup so let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
boy boy do we have a lot of [ __ ] around
up in the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends today let's go surfing
it's surfing time sorry that gabe
sanchez has gabe's got a couple days off
other than making thumbnails you know
gabe makes our thumbnails
then we talk back and forth but gabe has
a couple days off so i'm going to be
surfing the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets by myself today with all the you
folks but gabe will not be joining us
today and probably not tomorrow he'll
rejoin us on friday
where we
go through bonenet of the week
so make sure to go follow us on twitter
at tonymichaelspod
to vote or follow us here on youtube you
can also vote on youtube now
for the bonehead of the week which will
come the poll will come out tomorrow and
gabe will join us on friday
for the bonehead of the week he's still
working behind the scenes though
and he he gave us this great um
thumbnail for today let me let me see if
i can find it here here it is he gave us
this great thumbnail for well maybe
there we go he gave us this great
thumbnail for today
under investigation
he wanted to he wanted me to let the
audience know no gabe is okay people are
asking him gabe is okay he just has a
few days off he went to a secret bunker
he's got a few days that he's doing some
things so he'll he won't be on the show
he's still working behind the scenes
though
he just does not have the the internet
capability in the new bunker that he is
in
um to stream he can still send great art
like we have here on the thumbnail today
but he did want to
he did want me to let the
the audience know that he told you so
doubt me as we say here on the tony
michaels podcast of course trump was
under investigation we've been saying
this to trust the department of justice
trust the system trust democracy trust
merit garland trust these things this is
happening there is no indication that it
wasn't happening
that was all a bunch of [ __ ]
so stop paying attention to people who
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about i guess that's a simple way of
putting it um we got a lot of video to
get to today and i want to start off
with merge
speaking of white christian nationalist
here's marjorie taylor green uh
i don't know who the [ __ ] this is this
guy this podcast that she's on this
traitor tv podcast or whatever the hell
it's called right they got a thousand of
these [ __ ] things
that's why the left should have a
thousand podcasts of their own if you
like to speak into a microphone you
should start your own show and gain your
audience and yell and scream into a
microphone if you can if that's what you
want to do for democracy or you can fill
out postcards make phone calls door
knock donate a little bit of money to
each campaign whatever you can do to
engage in your democracy so that way we
can indict and convict donald trump in
the 2022 midterms along with his allies
and all of his people all his political
candidates that have his endorsement
[ __ ] them let's indict all of them and
convict all of them in the 2022 midterms
by we the jury voting them the [ __ ] out
let's do that speaking of voting
[ __ ] out let's talk about merge
foot green now think about it though
they they're per they've purged the
military yeah they've purged the
military the lawyers are leaving
absolutely why do they want to be there
they're being tr they're going through
woke training they're they're toxic
masculinity is is completely not
accepted even though
what are the military for i would think
toxic masculinity is not accepted
what in the when in the [ __ ] when in the
[ __ ] did it become acceptable
for toxic masculinity in this game these
this goddamn fascist i am so sick of
this garbage we're white trump trumped
up white men are the most depressed
people in the country yes we we do not
want you here we don't want your
ideology we do not want nazis here we
don't want fascists in our democracy
what don't you understand we will not
tolerate intolerance
that is a thing we do not have to
[ __ ] do
as pro-democracy people in this country
we do not have to tolerate intolerance
[ __ ] you
liberalism is the is it's the toughness
of our country that's what makes america
tough is liberalism that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] fascism and authoritarianism you
[ __ ] weak pieces of [ __ ]
all you want to do is get one person one
person to tell you what to do and what
the [ __ ] to think and that's how you're
gonna go well that's [ __ ] easy
liberalism is hard compromise is hard
democracy's difficult we all know that
hell achieving equity and equality is
damn difficult in in any society
and democracy is the best way to deliver
that's what scares the [ __ ] out of these
trumped-up white dudes as she's
describing here that toxic masculinity
isn't allowed in the military
boo [ __ ] who
toxic masculinity does not make you a
man
i'm sorry you [ __ ] idiots it does not
make you a man or manly no matter how
much you tan your balls like tucker
carlson
toxic masculinity is horse [ __ ]
it's fascism it's ridiculous that's why
she loves it let's continue toxic
masculinity would be a number one reason
you think when you're being shot at you
could care less about those things yeah
they should be like are you a toxic male
yes please sign up
what the [ __ ] are you a toxic male yeah
yeah okay you are now on the fringes of
society we are going to ostracize you
[ __ ] you
again
folks we do not have to tolerate
intolerance
i get so sick and tired of people in
this country
like gloving these [ __ ] they're
nazis
charlie kirk you're a nazi marjorie
taylor gern green you're a [ __ ] nazi
donald trump
you're a [ __ ] nazi
send me a cease and desist i don't give
a [ __ ]
do it let's do it i'll publish it here
on the show
[ __ ]
pieces of goddamn [ __ ]
marjorie taylor green loves toxic
masculinity
once toxic masculinity is part of our
military and our police force well no
wonder we got a [ __ ] problem
speaking of more [ __ ] lying fascist
here's another one carrie lake listen to
this nonsense
this is posted by accountable gop look
at this [ __ ] garbage that she's
spewing it's some kind of event
we will not stand for another stolen
election that's right right no
we won't stand for it if there's gonna
be hell to pay if they try it and we're
working right now we're already
detecting some fraud i know none of you
are shocked
we're already detecting
what fraud fraud what what the [ __ ] are
you talking about this is carrie lake
she knows she's gonna lose her primary
here in arizona that's what's happening
here gary lake this this trumped-up
[ __ ] idiot is gonna lose her primary
and the reason why we're going to start
to see some of these candidates these
trump back candidates start to lose
their primaries is because we're already
watching the trump back candidates who
won their primaries [ __ ] getting
trounced absolutely [ __ ] trounced in
these senate races
jd vance dr oz herschel walker they're
getting [ __ ]
just
killed in these primaries with these
numbers and not just with the numbers
but with the messaging
and so it won't be surprising if some of
these other trump-backed candidates and
these pr in these late primaries start
to [ __ ] lose
but really honestly at this point maybe
we should be cheering on the
trump-backed candidates to get the
candidacy
we need to politicize this at every
measure folks that's right i said it i
keep saying it and i'll keep saying it
now until
the end of time we have to politicize
everything
we cannot let these fascists win dog
catcher
for [ __ ] sake
we have to fight at every single measure
at every single inch here
and yes if that means that some of these
psychopaths like carrie lake get the
nomination so that the state can go nope
not gonna [ __ ] elect you psycho
but we also have to band together as
pro-democracy voters and engage in the
ballot
we say it all the time here to have
strategic outrage to stay pissed about
these things that matter
and this nonsense that carrie lake is
spewing it [ __ ] matters
it matters in our election when you have
someone projecting that they want to
cheat
[ __ ] we see it in colorado with tina
peters under indictment for trying to
[ __ ] with the machines the only people
who have been proven and now under
criminal indictment for [ __ ] with
voting machines are republicans
you know who tina peters is she's the
one who appeared at mike lindell the
mypelo nazis
a cyber symposium over a year ago
this is just bonkers batshit crazy stuff
now listen to what else she says carrie
lake here
and nobody's been like oh no we're
already detecting fraud and we're
believe me we've got cyber folks working
with us we got lots of attorneys we got
cyber folks what the [ __ ] does that mean
cyber folks and we got lots of attorneys
here's what you can know about this
video and i wrote it
i wrote it here
i said so in summation there's no fraud
detected
there's no cyber folks whatever the [ __ ]
that means and there's no attorneys
because carrie lake is a [ __ ] liar
she is a [ __ ] liar and a traitor for
that matter to her country and we
watched as she turned her back on her
friends her personal friends
because she had to have the narrative of
drag queens or bad
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you want to see some more projection
i'll show you some more projection this
is the actual photo that is at the top
of the banner
on the former guys fraud social account
i'm not [ __ ] you this is it
you notice something about this [ __ ]
picture what do you notice about this
picture huh
there's something significant about this
picture here it really feels like to me
that these are all white men
and the stupid people point this out the
stupid [ __ ] thumbs up
did he take a [ __ ] picture without
that [ __ ] thumb
does he i don't know
i have no idea
but just look at this photo and the
reason why they put this photo at the
top of his [ __ ] his fraud social
account
the reason why they use this photo is
because the narrative right now in this
country is that donald trump donald
trump sicked his violent mob to kill
police officers
on january 6 and they did kill police
officers there's right now there's
breaking news let me see if i can find
it here
now there's breaking news uh from the
courtroom in washington let's see if we
can go to at the refresh here a bit
[Music]
uh
scott mcfarlane had it here it is alert
plea hearing scheduled this afternoon in
a high profile january 6 case of george
tanios
who was accused of assaulting capital
officer brian sitnick who later died of
multiple strokes
so
they change
they change his header to him standing
there loving a bunch of white cops right
oh yay these are my brown shirts this is
my essay
all because
we're gonna have a plea hearing for the
person who helped kill
a police officer
george tanios
one of the trumped up white dudes who
was sick on the capitol
to go kill police officers back to blew
my [ __ ] ass
that's why donald trump and his social
media team
are posting that
at the top of his banner
on his fraud social account
[ __ ] that guy
okay uh let's go back here's another
video
of marjorie taylor green talking about
the war on white men
more [ __ ] white christian nationalism
[ __ ]
here we go let's listen but i really
believe there's a war on men and no one
will talk about it and i think it's
awful um
men are our leaders men men are
protectors men are fathers they guide
our kids and protect our families and
provide for our families
but that is something that is that has
been shamed uh for decades now yeah what
the [ __ ] is she talking about
what is she that men are ostracized
because
they're supporters of their family
their providers who the [ __ ] says that
[ __ ]
when have you ever heard that [ __ ]
of an actual real man not a toxic
masculine masculine man marge
but a real man
a real man or a woman for that matter
who gives a [ __ ] who's the head of the
household
no one talks bad about the hell ahead of
the household who provides for their
family
who's a good parent to their children
unlike you [ __ ] who can't
concentrate on anything but genitalia
that's all you [ __ ] weirdos talk
about all you want to talk about is
[ __ ] pronouns genitalia
and and and sexualizing children for
crying out loud that's all they want
it's all these weirdos want to talk
about jesus christ and then we'll get to
it here maybe we'll watch the video
where the vice president united states
has a meeting and people pronounce their
pronouns and they describe what they're
wearing and what they look like because
they were blind folks in the room and
the goddamn meeting was about the
americans for disabilities act jesus
christ
you [ __ ] monsters let's listen to
this she talks about how it's sad that
cops that cops are held accountable with
body cam i'm not [ __ ] you she says
it's it's it's a bad thing that police
officers are held accountable with body
cams listen and it's it's so frustrating
frustrating especially here at this
place where we are for this generation
oh my gosh they are such victims of it
but we see it pronounced uh with law
enforcement oh such victims oh such
victims oh we're victims us nazis or
victims hitler would be really
disappointed in these [ __ ]
don't you think these ninka poop nazis
like marjorie taylor green complaining
about about how they're oh we're so
oppressed
hitler would be ashamed of these
[ __ ] these ninja poop nazis
don't you think jesus christ enforcement
where those those gosh those great guys
those police officers that want nothing
more than to protect their community
keep their communities safe um they it's
like their hands are tied behind they're
not faking cuffs like aoc
yeah but real ones
like they can't even function they have
they're on video every second of the day
on the job um and and i can't understand
how they can do a good job under that
microscope how in the [ __ ] doesn't
anyone know that almost everyone no
matter where you work or where you're at
you're on [ __ ] video camera
like this is 2022 you dumb sons of
[ __ ] it doesn't really matter almost
anywhere you're at anywhere that you're
at
in public you're on a [ __ ] video
camera somewhere a secure a private
security camera a public security camera
someone's cell phone what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
they're they're oppressed because they
are held accountable by wearing a body
cam they have to make sure they do their
job according to the law or the video
cam will tell the truth you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of here with
this nonsense with this drivel
absolute dribble to cry and tear up for
a bunch of toxic white trumped up white
dudes get the [ __ ] out of here because
she failed to mention the women who were
[ __ ] police officers in this country
she failed to mention them she probably
wants them to wear body cams she doesn't
even want them to be police officers
because they don't have toxic
masculinity
[ __ ] just garbage human being she is
a garbage [ __ ] human being and a nazi
she's a [ __ ] nazi we have to say this
out loud we can't cower from this stuff
of calling these people what they are
they're [ __ ]
nazis
nazis and here's the
the nazi the maga king himself donald
trump at some kind of [ __ ] i don't
know some nazi rally i'm not sure
exactly which one this is i think this
is the america first nazi rally that
they had in washington dc here he's
talking about setting up concentration
camps
i'm not [ __ ] you he's talking about
setting up concentration camps listen
all kinds from all places lying along
the roads that's without the tents
and then you look at the tents and the
homeless
and you say what's happening to this
great bastion
perhaps some people will not like
hearing this but the only way you're
going to remove the hundreds of
thousands of people and maybe throughout
our nation millions of people now some
people pointed out because he's talking
about homeless people here but this is
this is what they do
pay attention to this because he's
talking about homeless people but that
is not their aim here that it's not
their aim and their rhetoric
just like just like they [ __ ] bitched
and complained about abortion and
overturning roe v wade that wasn't their
[ __ ] aim their aim was to take away
rights from women and their next move is
to take away all contraception and all
choice of cap reception from all
americans not just women but men as well
and the next move is for their [ __ ]
vote women's vote
this [ __ ] nonsense that he's wanting
to create concentration camps and he'll
get to it here he gets to his great plan
on how to set up concentration camps
dave he's talking about homeless people
and a goal dad
buy a free gold coin
qualify for a free gold coin what the
[ __ ]
as he's talking about homeless people
but listen to the end because this is
important this is important the rhetoric
and they're gonna start every one of
these [ __ ] are gonna start
saying this garbage because he's puking
it into a microphone listen talking
about
and help make our cities clean safe and
beautiful again
is to open up large parcels of
inexpensive land and the outer reaches
of the cities are you paying attention
he wants to open up large parcels of let
cheap land
well we can get it cheap and we can send
folks
wink
ring medical professionals
including doctors psychiatrists
psychologists you mean the same ones
that deny science the ones that you find
to deny science those ones the [ __ ] out
of here with this [ __ ]
drug rehab specialists
build permanent bathrooms and other
facilities make them good make them hard
oh yeah great great they can take a [ __ ]
at least you can take a [ __ ] in this
concentration camp there's a great
bathroom listen
but build them fast
and create
thousands and thousands of high quality
tents which can be done in one day one
day
and you have to move people out now some
people say oh that's so horrible no
what's horrible
is what's happening now
because now they're intense but most of
them aren't even tense that function
so here he is here he is i'm telling you
i'm telling you he's saying this [ __ ] as
if he wants this for homeless people
i know that's what it [ __ ] sounds
like at first breath
but wait this is concentration camp type
talk they're going to start [ __ ]
saying it out loud they're going to
start trumpeting it
in these
[ __ ] podcasts and [ __ ] it's going to
happen
it's going to happen
i mean you have uh folks like this
who are marjorie taylor green supporters
and marjorie taylor green supports them
this is nick fuentes
on i i don't know i think this is uh
telegram i think is the the garbage
social media site that this is
but nick fuentes implies that aids and
monkey pox are are gay people quote
unquote diseases
says quote it's like black people in
jail
taylor green speaks to these groups of
people like nick fuentes nick fuentes is
going to take what donald trump just
said and talk about how we should set up
concentration camps
guaranteed hundred percent oh they're
gonna start parroting that [ __ ] that's
why that's what they do they put this
stuff in the universe and they let these
[ __ ] take it hook line sinker
and run with it
but here nick fuentes is posting he post
on telegram this [ __ ] nazi he posts
gay people can't stop having sex with
multiple anonymous partners enough not
to get monkey pox
there's so much [ __ ] just garbage and
lies number one why what what what what
the [ __ ] are you talking about just
because of who you who you love means
that you you can't stop having sex with
multiple it sounds like projection nick
sounds like projection
it sounds like projection
kind of a wake-up call to the rest of
society and then he goes on to [ __ ]
puke up this nonsense they're not even
there's not even that many gay people
again more projection from nick fuentes
i think but everyone with monkey pox is
gay what the [ __ ] is he talking about
it's like aids he says which monkey box
is nothing not even close to like aids
he says how do people not see what's
going on here because it's not happening
you [ __ ] nazi and then he follows it
up with this one it's like black people
with jail
ah jesus christ
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
but this is who marjorie taylor green
listens to this is her best buddy she
goes and speaks at his event the event
that we just watched trump the event
that we just watched trump act where he
was talking about setting up tent cities
on on on cheap ass land where he can
send people that he doesn't like because
they're dirtying up the cities
it's called america first
nick fuentes his show
his entire organization is called
america first they're [ __ ] nazis
folks and call them that
need to stop this nonsense here's um
a report from this morning from scott uh
mcfarlane cbs news reporting federal
prosecutors are asking about trump's
discussion with california lauria john
eastman
and the and about pressure exerted on
pence this is where the investigation's
going folks this is how we're confirming
that the department of justice
has an investigation and has had an
investigation into the crimes that the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
has committed
he tried to steal our vote
he tried it didn't he didn't succeed but
he tried and the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup the first attempt was a bust but
they're still trying the cheeto dust
coup attempt now
and now that we know and now that we can
confirm that the department of justice
is criminally investigating donald trump
and his allies for trying to steal the
2020 election
we in the court of public opinion we're
the prosecutors and we're the jury
here in the court of public opinion
and it's time that we make our case to
the public
it's time that we engage in our
democracy
now's the time to stay pissed and use
our strategic outrage to save our
democracy from these fascist white
christian
nazis
now's the time
right now so engage in your democracy
any way you can find a way
find a way one way is to come here every
single weekday monday through friday for
two full hours noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific i will give you
i will give you the cathartic ability to
stay pissed and to have that strategic
outrage to protect your democracy
two hours every single day on youtube
twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
the midas touch facebook page we will be
back tomorrow same time same place don't
miss it
until tomorrow surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
meal born head ass speaking